[Música]
los padres de todo eeuu enfrentan
dificultades para encontrar fórmula
láctea para bebés ya que los problemas
en las cadenas de suministro junto a una
retirada masiva de estos productos por
motivos de seguridad han hecho con
muchas de las principales marcas
desaparezcan de los estantes tras meses
de escasez en farmacias y supermercados
el desabasto se ha visto agravado por el
retiro de estos productos realizados por
abbott nutrition que en febrero se vio
obligada a cerrar su mayor planta de
producción de fórmula láctea en eeuu por
motivos de contaminación y para ello
para seguir hablando sobre este tema
está por supuesto en el estudio más
romeros a la marca que más tenemos sobre
esta problemática que otros datos pues
vamos a repasar primero estas últimas
noticias como decías es un impacto muy
grande en las familias especialmente
esas de ingresos bajos por ahora la
fábrica abbott como decías él dice que
no ha encontrado rastros de la bacteria
que habría contaminado estos productos
una bacteria que se llama cronobacter
sacada sacada aquí perdón por ahora ha
provocado cinco infecciones y dos de
estas dos de estos niños han muerto by
den ha dicho que va a mejorar las
importaciones a tratar de mejorar la
producción de otros fabricantes pero
vamos a repasar los datos alrededor del
uso de fórmula en eeuu para tener algo
de contexto son dos de cada cinco bebés
los que ya usan una fórmula láctea para
pues para bebés incluso en los dos
primeros días de edad esa cifra aumenta
hasta un tercio en antes de los tres
meses y antes de los seis meses es
importante también destacar que sólo el
25 por ciento de los bebés en eeuu
tienen solo lactancia exclusiva antes de
los 6 meses que es la recomendación de
la organización mundial de la salud que
solo se alimentan de leche materna
durante los primeros 6 meses de edad
vamos a recordar también un informe que
publicó la organización mundial de la
salud a inicios de este año y es que la
mitad de los padres en todo el mundo han
recibido publicidad agresiva por parte
de la industria de esta leche formulada
para bebés algo que dicen pues que
interrumpe este proceso de lactancia
materna y que va en contra de los
intereses nutricionales de los propios
bebés entonces pues vamos a aprovechar
hoy también con la doctora que vamos a
entrevistar para reflexionar también
alrededor de estas dependencias de la
leche formulada así es marina mejor
también como lo hizo en los pediatras
que la leche materna la naturaleza pues
no se equivoca en cuanto a nuestro
organismo se refiere para eso entonces
queremos saludar a la doctora simpatía
ayuso ya es pediatra especialista en
nutrición infantil y médico cirujano
además profesora de pediatría académica
por la academia de pediatría e
investigadora de conacyt doctora gracias
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 la verdad es un
gusto que nos acompañe en la mañana de
hoy lunes para hablar de este tema tan
delicado le preguntó entonces doctora
qué sabemos de esta infección por esta
bacteria
sabemos que hay un lote de la marca
abbott que estuvo contaminada por esta
bacteria y que la ingestión de esta
bacteria llevó a que los niños tuvieran
enfermedades sin embargo el bloqueo
comercial se hizo a todos los lotes en
lo que se llevaba a cabo la
investigación y esto llevó a que hubiera
un desabasto no nada más de esa marca en
particular sino que otros papás que no
podían acceder a esta marca empezaron a
consumir otras marcas y eso ocasionó una
escasez general de fórmulas en ciertos
países
claro doctora sí marc no sé si tiene
usted usted de alguna pregunta es si de
hecho quería preguntarle qué
consecuencias tiene para los bebés
precisamente no poder alimentarse de la
fórmula tanto de la misma marca que
estaban usando como tener que recurrir a
otros alimentos
a través de los años hemos estado cada
vez utilizando más fórmulas y se ha
intentado que estas fórmulas sean lo más
parecido en sus componentes a la leche
materna sin embargo como ustedes bien lo
dijeron previamente lo mejor es la
alimentación con leche materna y puede
ser esta un área de oportunidad
importante para poder fomentar de nuevo
esta alimentación
directamente al pecho de mama que
finalmente contiene los mejores
nutrientes para estos niños te podemos
hacer
podemos tanto platicar o dar información
con estas madres incluso previo a la
gestación o algunas técnicas de
lactancia o incluso en algunos países y
utilizar lo que se llama banco de leche
que son madres que pueden tener
suficiente leche y que incluso pueden
llegar a donar leche materna para que
otros niños puedan aprovecharse y
alimentarse de leche humana y no
necesariamente el leche de fórmula en
caso de que no pueda conseguirse leche
materna algunos padres han
a traer la leche de otros países y lo
que nosotros como pediatras podemos
hacer aparte de fomentar lo previamente
escrito podemos empezar con la
alimentación temprana desde las 17 o 20
semanas alrededor de los cinco meses por
ahí de alimentación con otro tipo de
cosas como pudieran ser frutas verduras
o algunas proteínas pero mientras tanto
pues también platicar con los
proveedores de la importancia que
requiere esta forma claro doctora y
también pues yo le quiero preguntar por
otras alternativas también que sean
muchísimas más seguras pues teniendo en
cuenta y aterrizando este problema que
estamos viviendo en eeuu con escasez de
leche de fórmula y también teniendo en
cuenta que no es fácil encontrar pues
leche materna pues en el mercado no y
además también la importancia a nivel
sentimental y de afecto que el niño
pudiera tener de la red digamos cuando
la mamá da pecho a la diferencia a la
leche de fórmula no
definitivamente en pediatría lo
denominamos apego que es lo que
desarrollan los niños por tener el
contacto piel con piel con la mama y
definitivamente hay cosas que tienen la
leche materna que por más avanzados que
estemos en tecnología no se ha podido
agregar a las fórmulas infantiles si la
pregunta es si pudiéramos ofrecer otros
alimentos o poder alimentar estos niños
con algo diferente a la leche materna oa
leche de fórmula los primeros cuatro
meses no hay otro tipo de leche de
fórmula es decir fórmulas que se hacen a
base de soya a base de leche de cabra
pero estas deben de ser fortificadas
creo que aquí lo más grave
donde los padres en problema en un
poquito más no es nada más cuando la
unión citan una fórmula porque no tienen
acceso a la leche materna de alguna
manera o que la madre puede estar fuera
de casa sino el problema más grande que
yo veo en pediatría es cuando estos
niños no pueden tomar leche de fórmula
normal es por decir así
niños que tienen alergia a las proteínas
de la leche de vaca niños que tienen
intolerancias a ciertas cosas como la
lactosa niños que necesitan fórmulas
especiales y que no pueden alimentarse
de leche materna ahí es donde se vuelve
un problema de mucho más importante por
supuesto doctora de hecho queríamos
preguntarle también por algo que ya
estaba apuntando no porque se toma tanta
leche de fórmulas cuando la
recomendación desde la pediatría desde
la oim y ese es que se se trate de
priorizar la lactancia materna que qué
factores influyen allí y también pues
sin ánimo de juzgar las madres y las
alegrías que deben aprovechar pues las
fórmulas porque no tienen otra forma
definitivamente creo que tenemos un
sobreconsumo de fórmulas cuando lo que
deberíamos de hacer es nosotros como
médicos informar y promover la lactancia
materna que es la mejor alimentación que
pueden tener los niños y la vamos a
comiéndose a los primeros seis meses
pero que idealmente se prolongue hasta
los dos años de edad creo que en este
boom de estar teniendo la publicidad
para que los niños puedan consumir cosas
que pueden ser artificiales nos ha
llevado a abusar del uso de esas
fórmulas e incluso desde antes desde los
nacimientos la mayoría de los
nacimientos deberían ser por vía vaginal
y muchos se están haciendo por cesárea
sin tener una indicación como tal y
desde ahí va el problema entonces
debemos de recurrir más a lo natural y a
lo que cada cuerpo ofrece y solamente
utilizar la fórmula aquellas madres que
realmente no pueden hacerlo o bien
aquellos niños que necesitan de otro
tipo de alimentación doctora estaba
hablando también de esas cosas que no se
han podido agregar nunca a las fórmulas
no por ejemplo la organización de la sal
también decía que esta leche materna es
una primera me gustaría que nos pudiera
desarrollar un poco más alrededor de
esto no de qué aporta más allá de
nutrientes esta lactancia en los
primeros meses de vida me encanta tu
pregunta la leche materna tiene al que
se llama inmunoglobulina a que es una
proteína que generan las mamas en donde
están todos los anticuerpos de las
enfermedades que la mamá padeció y esto
no se puede hacer de forma artificial no
se puede agregar igea que es
precisamente lo que confiere esta
inmunidad y lo que hace que los niños
que estén alimentados con leche materna
puedan estar inmunológicamente más
fuertes que aquellos que están
alimentados con leche porque se han
agregado algunas otras cosas como el
glóbulo de grasa de la leche se han
estado agregando luteína y otras cosas
que con el paso del tiempo hemos
conocido que tiene la leche materna pero
hoy por hoy y después de años y años de
tener fórmula ninguna fórmula es igual a
la leche claro digamos autora también
cómo sería el desarrollo cognitivo y
también físico de un niño que toma pues
leche materna y leche de fórmula pues
teniendo en cuenta también que algunas
mamás no pueden dar teta digamos a sus
hijos
el desarrollo del bebé va a ser digamos
igual o va a tener algún tipo de
complicaciones solo por beber leche de
fórmula también teniendo en cuenta que
esta leche de fórmula a veces también
puede tener ingredientes como azúcar por
ejemplo que es tan dañino tan dañino
puede ser esto para un bebé
las leches de inicio no contienen azúcar
casi siempre estas son las leches de
continuación es decir las leches para
niños mayores de seis meses son mayores
de un año pero sí es verdad que hay
algunos estudios en los que indican que
los componentes que tienen la leche
materna le confieren a los niños un
desarrollo intelectual o un coeficiente
intelectual hasta de cuatro puntos más
que aquellos que consumieron leches de
fórmula y precisamente se apegó que se
tiene a través de la piel con piel que
no puede lograrse a través de un biberón
o de un utensilio que se utilice en
lugar del pecho directo en la mama así
que como decía inicialmente creo que
esta puede ser una excelente oportunidad
para que fomentemos más la lactancia
materna y que al final vamos a tener
seres humanos con mayor estado de
nutrición y con un mayor desarrollo de
ser oral entonces que más de aprovechar
de una oportunidad de una escasez para
poder sacar algo muy relevante y muy
importante también es importante
recordar que esto afecta de manera
desproporcionada a las familias de bajos
ingresos en el sentido de que las madres
que tienen que ir a trabajar antes en
peores condiciones laborales normalmente
tienen muchas menos oportunidades
después de poder amamantar a sus bebés
entonces pues también recordando estoy
teniendo esto en mente que se puede
hacer entonces a largo plazo como una
solución en también que vaya un poquito
más a la raíz de este problema que se
puede hacer para facilitar esta
lactancia materna en todos los estratos
sociales
pero que vale la pena que esto se
trabaje desde áreas de gobierno en donde
se le debe de dar a estas madres
trabajadoras un tiempo para poder
disfrutar de los beneficios de la leche
materna porque también tiene beneficios
para las madres o que incluso en centros
de trabajo existan lactarios o existen
espacios donde las mujeres puedan lactar
hay sociedades en algunos países
latinoamericanos en donde muchas madres
se ponen de acuerdo y hay madres que
están lactando y que se quedan en las
comunidades a lactar no nada más a sus
hijos sino a otros hijos que requieren
leche materna mientras otras mujeres
salen a buscar precisamente los recursos
para poder mantenerse como familias pero
definitivamente es algo que debemos de
hacer desde el gobierno los pediatras
los padres de familia es algo que
debemos de fomentar y que al final de
cuentas pues va a repercutir en la salud
de toda la comunidad
pues doctora gracias por su tiempo por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 para tratar este tema de esta
escasez de leche en eeuu pero también
para tratar la importancia de lo que es
la leche materna para el desarrollo de
los bebés no mar por supuesto al final y
tratar de ir a la raíz de los problemas
no más allá de esta escasez particular
también va a hacer que a futuro estemos
mejor y no vuelva a pasar y como también
lo decidas tomar con estas desigualdades
también económicamente hay muchas
personas que no tienen los recursos
necesarios para comprarle una leche de
fórmula pues la más óptima para su bebé
es doctora nuevamente doy las gracias
por estar con nosotros en este espacio
de france 24 un abrazo muchas gracias
estábamos conversando con la doctora sí
patria ayuso pediatra especialista en
nutrición infantil y además el médico
cirujano nosotros continuamos esto es
directo américa que es con nosotros
[Música]